la deuxième circonscription de saône et
loire regroupe le charolais brionnais un
territoire majoritairement rurale enclin
à droite tandis que des villes comme de
nombreux bonds lancy sont plutôt de
gauche
et comme la députée sortante ne se
représente pas cette circonscription
certainement l'une des plus incertaines
du département les candidats ne s'y
trompe d'ailleurs pas à l'image de
josiane corneloup cette pharmacienne
conseillère départementale qui se
présente sous l'étiquette des
républicains restent prudentes tout en
jouant la carte le cas je ne fais pas de
prévisions dans le cadre de cette
élection je pense que voilà il faut une
fois tant il faut voir et je pense que
les électeurs seront tout de même
sensible à ma présence sur le terrain
puisque je suis tout de même connu tout
au moins dans le charolais brionnais
parce que ça fait dix ans qu'ils aient
lu sur le charolais brionnais et je
pense avoir porté des projets
suffisamment important pour que la
population ait conscience de
l'investissement qui a été le mien et de
mes engagements voulons toutes ces
années autre marché autres candidats
entretuent jik conseiller régional front
national depuis 2015
il est également assistant parlementaire
européen de ce film montel et il prône
la défense des services publics
à 24 ans c'est le plus jeune candidat
honnêtement si je suis élu demain député
je serai pas totalement
dans un environnement nouveau pour moi
je connais les questions
budgétaire déjà j'ai fait du droit où je
suis parfaitement à l'aise avec
l'élaboration de la loi et en sagesse
est vrai que par rapport à d'autres
certains de mes concurrents qui n'ont
qui je pense n'ont pas les compétences
pour ce rôle je eu effectivement faire
la différence
autre jeune candidat vincent chauvet 29
ans président du modem 71 il est investi
par la république en marche
ce chef d'entreprise dans le numérique
souhaite amener un renouvellement
politique et des idées bien précises
c'est vraiment redynamiser revitaliser
la circonscription lui donner un avenir
ce que fait ici corinne jourdain est
vraiment exemplaire elle a pris elle a
repris cette industrie on doit être fier
plus que de la céramique la plus vieille
usine de digoin elle en a fait un
instrument qui est aujourd'hui
remarquable qui exportent à
l'international c'est exactement la même
démarche que je veux impulser que ma
candidature
vincent chauvet est également 4e adjoint
de la ville d'autun qui se trouve dans
une autre circonscription
d'ailleurs dominique lotte maire de
gueugnon dénonce un parachutage et a
finalement décidé de se présenter sous
l'étiquette du parti radical de gauche
aujourd'hui je pense que le parti dans
marche
le parti de la république en marche a
fait une faute sur un territoire comme
le nôtre qui est un territoire rural qui
est attaché un certain nombre de valeurs
qui mérite des élus qui connaissent bien
le territoire qui connaissent bien la
population qui connaissent bien les
acteurs locaux les acteurs économiques
c'est je crois ce que je suis et donc
c'est bien encore une fois ce qui a
porté ma volonté de dialogue
autre particularité du charolais
brionnais c'est l'unique circonscription
de saône et loire où le parti communiste
et la france a soumises ont décidé de
faire un ticket commun pour ces
militants c'est tout simplement pour une
évidence ces personnes leur idée qu'on
va la loi y compris qui favorise les
licenciements abusifs
c'est remettre l'humain au coeur de la
société
c'est promouvoir la paix l'entente
et puis au niveau du charolais c'est
travailler en local les circuits courts
pour les agriculteurs pour la filière de
viande par exemple c'est aussi tenter de
réunir les gens pour que les projets ou
puissiez discuter de construire a dû
porter ensemble avec au total treize
candidats des alliances inédites et une
arrivée surprise
2e circonscription de saône et loire
sera particulièrement intéressant
d'analyser au regard des chiffres du
premier tour une triangulaire n'est
d'ailleurs pas à exclure et sont aussi
candidats dans cette 2e circonscription
one et sabu draps pour le ciel eric
nevers dlf dominique ornais europe
écologie pascal dussauge lots lorraine
destrem opc défilé guyot de caila les
autres on t'a huppert et nous devons
mentionner aussi la candidate divers
gauche philomène baccot qui a retiré sa
candidature après la date limite de
dépôt